I've had five roommates in my lifetime
before living with my current partner I
lived with three gay guys ah where's the
third one he's in the bathroom doing a
line sounds like him and before them I
moved in with a friend from high school
we weren't terribly close or anything
but we were both pursuing acting so we
decided hey let's move out to LA
together I lived in the loft
she had the downstairs bedroom and we
shared one bathroom I learned a lot
about living with someone else
especially that you shouldn't walk
around naked what they don't like that
but you see there was always one source
of conflict between me and my roommate I
maneet for anything and she's not okay
you win it was a usual stuff you know
dishes left out that weren't big soaked
here in the sink whatever but then one
day my roommate had to go use the
bathroom for number two and the toilet
clogged and overflowed now you think
when this happens you would freak the
fuck out and 4:09 that shit but instead
of cleaning the bathroom
my roommate decided she would put rain
boots outside of the door rain boots
then three days went by and finally I
could not stand it anymore so I good I
decided to clean the bathroom Oh so
whenever you think you're having a
crappy day remember me remember the
bathroom
seriously I'm cleaning someone shit